le bonheur de jolis pour vous le savez
tous les jeudis jean luc lemoine nous
fait ces questions en 4/3 on va revenir
sur ce qui s'est passé dans cette
émission cette semaine et ce qui s'est
passé au sein de l'équipe jean luc ayé
c'est pas beau mais vraiment pas passé
jamais très bon mais ça va je suis bonne
humeur puisque vous avez perdu votre
pari alors ouais c'est vrai allez une
question tout de suite bonjour cyril je
m'appelle jacques c'est étrange mais
plus les semaines passent plus j'ai
l'impression que vos chroniqueurs
deviennent des bills
est ce que vous les aérer entre les
émissions alors je ne peux pas vous
laisser dire ça mais camara ne sont pas
débiles ils sont juste étrange par
exemple gilles verdez gibert et ce
pendant les pauses il faut savoir qu'il
s'entraîne à applaudir
c'est un peu flippant on dirait rain man
un plus
christophe carrière lui est beaucoup
plus équilibré regarder
ok
non je retire yaya que des barjots dans
l'équipe il appelle morini-bosc par
exemple elle a un don de se mettre en
pause en pleine émission juste pour
économiser ses batteries je vais sur
c'est l'image la plus étonnante de
l'année c'est très impressionnant
regardez décousu parfois un enchaînement
de séquences qui était trop rapide pour
moi j'étais un peu paumé et voilà la
troisième restrictions c'est sûr et
nohra moi je préfère mais c'est
subjectif l'assument et laura dans un
registre plus agressif déstabilisant
plus les invités les mettant hors de
leur zone de confort pour leur faire
dire des trucs nouveaux
j'aurais préféré voir
oui celle ouvrant des comptes à sion des
vrais malades à me faire mais c'est
incroyable c'est ça non mais je pense
qu'ils avaient fort est un cyborg où
nous luttons est fait des choses que
personne ne peut faire au monde je vais
vous révéler un secret mais travaille
beaucoup et isabelle donc souvent
isabelle arrive fatigué à l'émission
mais elle réussit à faire illusion grâce
à deux choses premièrement c'est la
seule femme au monde capable de rire
pendant son sommeil si pendant son
sommeil ainsi dix ans déjà
ben c'est du direct regardez la elle rit
pendant qu'elle dort gallésie tous les
cinq ans
en fait cessé entre le rire le
somnambulisme et deuxièmement si
isabelle est toujours impeccable
démission bah c'est surtout grâce à vous
si c'est vrai mais oui cyril série qu'il
trouve toujours les mots juste avant
l'émission pour lui dire de bien se
tenir
80 bosse ici
et voilà isabelle je les vis de secret
il faut le savoir si l'émission a de la
tenue
c'est parce que nous avons tous à
l'esprit que nous devons être droit
comme décisif
si lille a toujours le bouge
voilà là haut c'est un guide pour nous
il faut soit que cyril a toujours le mot
juste
sauf peut-être pour les inviter à il ya
deux semaines nous recevions jean reno
et tom leeb ou là faites attention était
bien oui mais faites attention aux
liaisons cyril parce que ça a choqué
beaucoup de gens moi aussi je peux
quitter le plateau
connais pas oui c'était jean reno jean
rectum c'est un acteur de file droit
dont vous avez dit jean rectum que c'est
rien bah c'est pas ce oui j'aime bien
c'est bien mais c'est un très bon acteur
sigean rectum c'est fou demandé jean
michel alors lorsque cyril est notre
guide donc dit que nous sommes perdus et
bah qu'est ce qu'on fait on l'appelle on
l'appelle le problème c'est qu'avec le
bruit du plateau et ne nous entend pas
toujours c'est pas grave il suffit
d'assister
si cédric cyril babin
non
daisy tunisie tunisie au stade montois
boursouflé san jose est atteint de
savoir se fait que dix fois on t'appelle
tu réponds à jo d'athènes les deux c'est
pareil je pars et je vais laisser paris
bah vous connaissez maintenant le vrai
nom de syrie ces jo ont ratifié cette
carrière s'il avait gardé
enfin pour ceux ci ont lancé un hashtag
gelato avec les gens et société john
atta mills et qui reste en deçà ce temps
pascal tard ça se tente
belle et demain donnera en direct à
partir de 18h30 dans touche pas à mon
poste
bon alors il est discret mais à la
décharge de s'il faut avouer que c'est
parfois compliqué de comprendre et nora
certains reprochaient n'aura pas de tout
un peu trop forcé son personnage en
employant du langage jeune et bah c'est
faux car quand tu n es pas l'antenne
c'est pire car nous sommes la changer
c'est mon gars c'est c'est quand t'as
pas là de bain c'est mieux la barre
frère était banquier à l'époque
en banque
vous pouvez nous écrire si vous avez
compris cette phrase non mais laissez
pas facile la vie de série dans
l'émission que tous les jours pour nous
divertir
il crée des nouveaux jeux avec des gages
par exemple être obligés de manger des
choses dégueulasses c'est le plaisir de
cyril c'est très efficace
vous voulez savoir ce que fait isabelle
morini-bosc nouveaux gages quand vous
avez le dos tourné quasi sûr prévient ça
fait un peu peur non je vous le dis je
suis la grèce affectée bon c'était pour
un pilote
mais pour nous on a fait ensemble on n'a
jamais été diffusé ces horribles
j'adorais ce truc ça s'appelle le people
chaud et vous êtes si elle savait parce
que cette femme est en détresse a oui
cette fameuse t bonds à elle vraiment
oui c'était quoi je sais plus ce que
c'était mais c'était très bon ça ne fait
pas de bons rails ces liquides j'aime
bien d'accord on va prendre
500 c'est à ce moment là qu'il faut
enchaîner pas m'engager
il ya deux semaines vous vous en
souvenez peut-être j'ai fait cette
rubrique déguisé en amanda lear oui à
cause de mon ancienne amie valérie
benaïm eva je voulais pas revenir sur
cet épisode
mais je suis tombé sur des images qui
m'ont troublé ça se passait juste au
moment où j'étais parti me changer
ses premiers pas du tout dans les
flammes ont témoigné
c'est un peu comme la sodomie
aujourd'hui
c'est moche il y avait donc une
conspiration contre moi même si le plus
content reste jean michel comme
d'habitude paris évidemment la question
qu'on peut se poser c'est pourquoi jean
michel est il si méchant avec tout le
monde
j'ai enfin trouvé l'explication
attention niveau mauvaise foi vous faire
venir un huissier
tout commence par un compliment de
jean-michel oui c'est étonnant mais il
trouvait très jolie les tennis de notre
assistante l'assitante ria mais il
regarde et je n'étais ni sa famille ni
manger des glaces est super jolie
m'étais vraiment odieux toit du gentil
je me dis qu'elles sont jolies
après je dis la vérité mais pourquoi tu
m'en voulait faire plaisir c'est pas
bien tu l'as tuée lundi d'erreur si
l'antenne
monde tu fais plaisir que le monde ne
les ai pas comme toi quelle mauvaise foi
pascal voulais pas le prendre une
semaine alors donc pour jean michel
sortir une saloperie c'est juste pour
faire plaisir on est d'accord c'est
visible non je dis qu'elle était jolie
après la cantine ou non mais si c'est ça
ta théorie je vais essayer de te faire
plaisir maintenant mais c'était faire
plaisir et on réellement une
conversation entre tirer toi que je
garder bien au chaud
ça faisait plaisir c'est ce qui apparaît
qu'aucune ton téléphone
alors c'est pas fini ses papiers si
c'était le premier épisode joli cul
thierry 10 ha du bout des lèvres il est
quand même un peu choqué enfin c'est ce
qu'il veut faire croire parce que
maintenant que je sais qu'il est aussi
complice du et amanda lear gates la
vérité deux minutes après cette
conversation
jean michel est parti aux toilettes et
il avait oublié son téléphone sur la
table non
essai
ce tournoi c'est pas quoi dire aux
téléspectateurs
l'équipe web et jean-michel je veux non
je voulais montrer ces images qualifie
son ami thierry jeu je sais que tu
m'aimes pas mais moi je t'aime moi je
t'aime alors pour une fois je vais te
montrer différemment aux gens aux basses
arriver non vraiment montrer que tu es
un homme debout qui aime les belles
choses
alors je vous préviens cet extrait n'est
pas drôle mais c'est juste pour te faire
plaisir
oui
salut tout ça a un côté beaucoup de
jetons
oui on l'ignoré mais jean-michel c'est
un amoureux du textile tulle ac au final
la chemise
non mais je compte le faire bah tu
devrais tu devrais franchement parce que
installé à ravir regarde comme elle te
mettait bien en valeur
puis
julie
la être méchant et ça il énervé au long
terme
vous l'avez vu chez vous ay les nerfs
des gens du club one alors puisqu'on est
dans les image valorisante
est ce que vous voulez savoir ce que
fait isabelle morini-bosc avant le début
de l'émission aussi non je sais je sais
pas si ça va vous plaira
et personne n'a vu ce calmant chinois
même responsable reprendre important
merde
il colle pas vous êtes comme les chewing
gum sous la table à personnes invitées à
les voir on attendait parce que je vais
regarder parce qu'elle attendait
justement annonce à se regarder à la
presse de pascal hélas pas là bas
non il n'a pas il est content de lui il
va trouver derrière pascal tomber sa
personne tout à l'heure mais c'était pas
les vraies celles à plusieurs maisons
c'est pas grave les dieux ou légèrement
levé après bien sûr vous l'enlevez après
les fastes des remords
elle ne s'arrête jamais allé mais bon on
lui pardonne tout et isabelle car chaque
semaine elle nous régale avec ses danses
et il a vous allez voir et s'est
déchaîné attention ce n'est pas de
reproduire ces mouvements chez google
ils ont été effectués par une
professionnelle
comme dirait que darche fait comparer
avec eux
fermée
il avait les mots
la mairie
m
soleil
tout le monde savait gaza
si tu
récré toit en bois debout les nageurs
qui sera oui oui aujourd'hui allez on y
va bonjour je m'appelle bachir souvent
dans notre émission cyril hanouna dit
qu'il est pakistanais
je voudrais dire que c'est impossible
on est beaucoup plus gros que lui salmi
tôt merci bâti réversible